das heißt nicht mal häufiger zur
vorsicht du kriegst du einfach faust und
fiktion was geht ab und willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja ich hab ja letztes
mal schon diese flashbacks gemacht da
wie das leider alleine gemacht und ja
ganz viele haben ganz viele haben mir
aber geschrieben ich soll das mit dem
kumpel wahr machen weil das dann
vielleicht ein bisschen witziger ist auf
jeden fall haben wir uns überlegt wir
machen das einfach mal das heißt wir
spielen jetzt gleich immer abwechseln
und der der weniger schafft darf sich
dann halt eine sache von diesen vier
sachen die wir ausgesucht haben
aussuchen und zwar wie einmal so ketchup
das heißt wenn ja also einmal haben wir
jetzt catcher das heißt wenn ich jetzt
zum beispiel gewinne und er sich ketchup
aus wählt dann damit eben diesen schönen
mund spritzen bis ein hund als haustier
das runterschlucken dann einmal so
komische 100 hunde leckerlis wie viel
haben wir gesagt oder 55 davon nehmen
einmal hier muskatnuss muskatnuss
komisch keine ahnung hat das ist auf
jeden fall ist nicht so lecker und hier
die zitronen zitronensaft also fangen
wir jetzt mal an mit runde eins ich habe
jetzt noch eine andere kamera die das
spiel so film wenn ich jetzt eine
schmiede und ich würde mal sagen ich
fahre dann ist er dran und gleich ist er
dran und nicht daran
also auf die plätze fertig los
20 x 24 ja also ich hätte jetzt 24 jetzt
eher dran
24 also er hat sich jetzt für dieses
zitronen dings entschieden und wir sagen
einfach mal muss es nicht ganz fertigen
sondern einfach so flugzeiten können so
einspritzen ja also auf die plätze
fertig los
na ja noch einmal apotheker einen großen
luft schnell dass der anspruch einer
ziemlich kurz dabei raus gibt einmal
probieren ja okay also jetzt nächste
runde
was machst du da gold gemäß 5 straffung
gibt okay er fängt jetzt an mach einfach
auf die plätze fertig los
bitte
niemals ich bei dir sind auf links apple
sie die röhre vier weitere ganz klar die
anleger vor geflickte ganz zentral aus
ich habe einfach aufgehört zu drücken er
hat 38 geschafft ja okay also jetzt ich
er hat jetzt wieviel 38 personen oder
auf die plätze fertig ich hab eigentlich
machen was sollen wir machen
30 ja okay also im mund problem ein
bisschen durch cut geschafft dreimal
runterschlucken erschaffst ungefähr
werden die wetten ich mache das ja okay
jetzt letzte runde also ich muss wieder
anfangen sagte weiter ich habe kein
fachkunde mutter also ok bitte los
geht's mit der bitte
also er muss jetzt mal erschöpft
so möchte sich ausgespuckt 55 man das
voll eklig
ich bin wasser nach bringen erst auf
essen unter stimmen und den weg ist
anlass tränen kämpfte
das kann man ihm herunterschlucken komm
wir gehen hier 2016 zusätzlich mit 3 1
doch ich das noch einmal essen hätte ich
mit was dich mal aufgegessen dritten
tricks denn runter jetzt erst mit einem
ohne wasser könnten
durch das wasser in der leider schon
wieder mit diesem video und ja wir
hoffen natürlich jetzt hat euch immer so
ein bisschen gefallen und die hat jetzt
auch ein bisschen was zum lachen und wir
als echt freuen wenn ihr einfach mal den
daumen nach oben gibt und es vielleicht
nur facebook lite wenn ihr bock habt
wenn ich da nicht aber ansonsten tag x
die beschreibung dafür instagram und so
weiter und ja hier unten links und
rechts geht so weiter mit meinen beiden
letzten videos könnt ihr auch machen und
ansonsten bin ich natürlich viel spaß
bei karneval und haut rein was macht man
am ende doch ein ende so